all right Findlay automotive group the
sponsors of this next segment offer an
incredible selection of new used and
certified pre-owned vehicles and they
are also champions of this community
always doing their part to make Southern
Nevada better and here to tell us more
about their partnership with an
incredible organization the after school
All-Stars is Tyler quarter CFO from
Findlay automotive group and Steph
Burness also with Finley but also a
board member of after school All-Stars
welcome you to it's great to be here I
love what you guys do for the community
Tyler I'm always so impressed with how
the family group the whole group is
always involved in making Southern
Nevada better why did you guys decide to
support after school nurse well it's a
it's an awesome organization and you
think about what they do and providing
kids opportunities after school and and
it's for uh for underprivileged kids a
little bit and give them some
opportunities to be successful so that's
an awesome program that we want to
support and now besides just supporting
them financially a little bit we're
actually getting personally involved
because staff burners who's here with me
and is our marketing director over at
Findlay Toyota has recently joined the
board for after school all-star so I
wanted to bring Steph on a little bit
and we today and we talk about what they
do and Stephanie you I know you
personally you're a very behind the
scenes person and you don't usually like
the spotlight on you but no you really
deserve it because being a board member
for this this great organization tell me
why you decided to become more involved
with them you know I went to school here
in Las Vegas and being a part of after
school All-Stars and being part of the
board it's important to give back and
give our time and they serve over 31
Title One schools here locally with
Henderson Las Vegas and North Las Vegas
and it's important for us to shine a
light for these children you know these
children get an opportunity to after
school it's like a two and a half hour
program so they get the chance to do
enrichment academics we also feed them
so it's really neat with what we can
provide that's really
um cool that you grew up here and you
know that uh Tyler what kind of what
kind of services have you seen your
staff provide like you mentioned
financially but it's more than that too
it's it's time it's it's it's volunteer
hours volunteer hours is funny we just
came from a volunteer event today that
we were doing with a group uh some of
our people but after school All-Stars is
a program we've been involved with for
many years you may remember Richard
bazden who used to be our general
manager Toyota he was on their board
years ago and so that's something we
just want to continue and uh because
giving back and trying to help the youth
in this community is something that we
really think is important and and this
is one of the best programs for that and
that's why we wanted to support them
yeah Steph people want to get involved
and help after school All-Stars how can
they how can they do that well what's
really neat is we're kicking off a
holiday campaign it starts November 29th
and it goes all the way to December 31st
so they can actually sponsor a student
which is really neat so you can start
off at 50 100 250 500 up to a thousand
or get a corporate sponsorship match and
we're we have that on our website so
it's
a-s-a-s-l-v.org now what does that get
if you sponsor a child what do they get
with that sponsorship I believe well a
lot of it's for the being able to
provide the teachers because we pay the
teacher that's actually at the school so
they're spending two and a half hours
with the students wow so it's in order
to have that same teacher have the same
interaction throughout the whole day
with them and then have two and a half
hours with them so being able to pay the
teacher and then the student gets you
know the academics they get enrichment
so we also get to take them on field
trips so they get to go to like the
wetlands red at Red Rock
hiking you know sports events so that
we've taken them to Vegas Golden Knights
game so it's really neat to be able to
provide that for the students you guys
really walk the walk and talk the talk
I'm really just so impressed with the
Findlay automotive group thank you guys
for all that you do and thank you guys
for being here and thank you for the
great car that I drive
thank you to the fiddly Automotive Group
for being one of our Community Pride
partners and we just can't thank them
for their support enough well just ahead
on Las Vegas now